- Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
- Go to Google and look up
the history, what the hell!
- Alright.
Hey, you're sweating a lot over here.
- I am sweating.
(silly music)
- Hi mom.
- Hi daughter.
- We're about to go into my search history
so Adam can see things about
me that he might not know.
- I'm gonna take this opportunity
and I'm just gonna go with it.
- Read anything, I don't care.
- Um, this is not that exciting, dad,
you Google some pretty weird shit here.
- Hair salons near me.
- Elbow clicks when I benchpress.
- When you get to a
certain age, your joints--
(exaggerated cracking sound effect)
start to click.
It's just normal for people my age.
- How to keep calm.
(chuckling)
- Map of USA.
Are you running away?
- Yes, I'm trying.
(laughing)
- [Stephanie] Take me with you!
- I'm looking at-- I see a handbag!
- Oh, that.
- Wow, a $2,000 handbag.
- But, we're just looking at it,
we weren't doing anything with it.
Cute though, right?
(scoffing)
And red.
- You watchin' some Netflix?
Were you chillin'?
- I was, yeah.
- Interesting.
- Sex hair for you?
- Oh.
- What?
- Yeah, mm.
- Sexy hairstyles to impress your husband.
(laughing)
- How long can a cat last
in a 90 degree house?
(laughing)
- I was workin' on a new look.
- Mom!
- I'm workin' on a new look.
- Oh my God!
- Roland, I'm workin' on
a new look honey, hello.
- Have you-- oh my God.
- Our AC went out during
the 114 degree heat wave--
(chuckling)
- Just the way you worded it was so--
- And I was really worried
that the cat might not survive.
- It says 'how long can it last.'
- Well, how long can a cat last?
Anything else you'd like to know?
- Great, great.
- Lingerie.
- I wanted to know!
- Lingerie!
I wanted to know, I wanted to know.
Don't judge me.
I mean, you'd better be
glad I am still sexy, hello!
(wheezing)
- Just as I suspected, your search history
is just as boring as you are.
Uh.
- I'm boring, I'm a nerd,
what do you want from me?
- Get the best body of your life.
New $1 trial for Dirty Days.
Oh look, there's a body builder.
Let's get fit together.
- Weed clinics?
- What?
- Wait, what is this?
- Wait, what?
- Weed maps?
- Oh, wow.
- Oh my god!
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Wait, first of all--
- And you were just getting on me.
- First of all--
Let me explain!
- Weed maps!
Oh my god.
- Explain!
- How to murder your wife,
it has nothing to do--
- It's called murder your wife?!
- It has noth-- it's with Jack Lemmon.
- What are you watching!
- Jack Lemmon stars in this movie.
- How To Murder Your Wife
is what you're watching?
Does mom know about this?
- Okay, okay, okay.
- I didn't even download that on purpose.
- It's not a download, you searched it.
Like, you literally
typed in 'weedmaps.com'
- I heard it was a new thing,
I was just trying to figure it out.
- It's a great movie,
have you ever seen it?
- No, what are you--
- It's a movie, How To Murder
Your Wife, it's a comedy.
- I didn't even search
that, my friend searched it,
you remember Kim from,
you know, over there--
when we--
my friend Kim?
(laughing)
- That was Kim.
- She ate an edible.
- She Googled my stuff.
I deleted it of course
because I didn't want you
to get in my phone,
- Mm.
I didn't want nobody to see it.
- Have you even ever smoked weed before?
Like...
- You don't have to say all that, okay,
in front of these people.
- My mother's still my mother.
- Yes, always.
- The search history was fun.
- Luckily that that's over,
it'll never happen again,
you will not be getting my phone.
I love him.
- I love her.
- Yes, he's amazing.
Aww!
(murmuring)
- I don't really need
Google cause I have him.
- I don't really need a
history book cause I have him.